Tagwache.
Keine Ruhe ohne Sicherung.
Keine Ruhe ohne Sicherung, danke.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht kommen gesehen, aber deswegen bin ich ja da, zum trainieren.
Der Truppenübungsplatz Allentsteig in Niederösterreich.
Ich bin hier mit dem Airchief der österreichischen Luftstreitkräfte verabredet.
In 15 Sekunden müsste er da sein.
Airchief, freut mich sehr.
Welcome to the Airforce.
Dankeschön!
Der Traum vom Fliegen.
Viele Junge Österreicherinnen und Österreicher würden gerne Pilotin oder Pilot werden.
Wenn man fliegen will, ist es eine perfekte Option.
Unsere Auswahlkriterien sind zwar sehr streng, aber wer das geschafft hat bekommt erstens
eine fantastische Ausbildung und dann auch noch einen sehr interessanten, sehr spannenden
und einen sehr abwechslungsreichen Beruf.
Für alle die sich für Technik und den verschiedenen Typen von Hubschrauber und Flugzeugen interessieren,
was haben wir denn in Österreich?
Wir haben eine beachtliche Hubschrauberflotte, immerhin 66 Stück, wenn wir von den Kleinen beginnen.
Die 10 Kiowas sind unser flexibelstes Gerät und das einzige bewaffnete Gerät.
Die 212 und die Black Hawks sind unser schweres Transportgerät.
Und die Alouette 3 ist ein relativ alter Hubschrauber, aber ein sehr verlässliches System
und bis heute unschlagbar im Hochgebirge.
Na dann, fliegen wir oder?
Naja, noch nicht ganz, es fehlt noch ein gewisses Bodentraining.
Ein Bodentraining?
Ja.
Ich habe es irgendwie gewusst, war irgendwie klar.
Bastlerhütte, südseitig, leicht renovierungsbedürftig.
Herzlich willkommen beim SERE-Training des österreichischen Bundesheeres.
Befreien aus Handschellen mit irgendetwas das man gerade dabei hat.
Robert du hast, glaube ich, eine Büroklammer eingesteckt.
Schlauer Fuchs.
Ganz genau wollen wir es jetzt auch nicht herzeigen, sonst kanns ja ein jeder.
Aber prinzipiell mach ich einmal diesen hier, hineinstecken...
Geh mit den Finger auf Kontakt mit der Handschelle, Jawohl, sehr gut.
Also, ich habe die Handschellen jetzt gelöst, oder zumindest irgendwie.
Jetzt bin ich aber dummerweise gefangen in einem Raum, wo ich nur über das Fenster flüchten kann.
Ich wusste nicht, dass man sich an Gartenschläuchen abseilen kann.
Er wird das einmal vorzeigen.
Ok, sehr fein.
Jetzt holt er eine Leiter, damit ich auch hinunter kann.
Ich habe mich für einen Feuerwehrschlauch entschieden.
Ok Männer, da beginnt jetzt der Fluchtparkour für euch.
Ihr habt jetzt viele Stationen praktisch durchgeübt.
Hier fassen wir alles zusammen.
Verstehe, wir werden gefesselt.
Mir ist es wichtig, dass ihr gefechtsmäßig
vorgeht, seid leise, sichert euch gegenseitig
und ihr macht die Geschichte so schnell wie möglich und kommt wieder in die Freiheit.
Los!
Ok.
So, erster Teil des SERE-Trainings.
Wir sind aus dem Gebäude raus und landen, wie sich sowas gehört, im Grünen und da
sind wir schon genau richtig für den zweiten Teil.
Ich glaube ich stehe im Wald.
Man hat mir gesagt, hier im Grünen finde ich offensichtlich eine Antwort.
Hallo Robert.
Ich darf dich herzlich willkommen heißen
bei der Ausbildung der österreichischen Luftstreitkräfte, der SERE-Ausbildung.
SERE ist eine Abkürzung für survival, evasion, resistance und escape.
Ok, ist natürlich vor allem zum Beispiel
wichtig für die österreichischen Luftstreitkräfte,
falls einmal irgendetwas passieren sollte.
Dazu hätte ich schon eine Ausrüstung für dich vorbereitet.
Sogenannte Überlebensweste.
Ok, was ist da alles drinnen?
Ein Personal-Locator-Beacon, Taschenlampen, Bussole, sprich Kompasse,
eine kleine Erste Hilfe Ausrüstung und eine sogenannte Überlebensdose.
Wenn ich bitten darf mir zu folgen.
Wie du hier siehst.
Hi, einer meiner Ausbilder.
Wir sind bei der ersten Station.
Die Station Feuer machen.
Man hat in der Überlebensdose verschiedene Sachen drinnen.
Du siehst hier einen Kienspan, das ist ein sehr harzhältiges Holz.
Man benötigt ein Messer und einen Feuerstarter.
Gut, also ich bohre hier mit dem Messer ein wenig hinein...
Man gräbt eine kleine Mulde, wie du dann
sehen wirst schlägt der Feuerstarter Funken.
Das ist ja genial.
Das Feuer haben wir hinter uns, dein nächstes Bedürfnis, was kannst du dir vorstellen?
Durst.
Durst!
So ist es.
Hol bitte Wasser.
Schaut ok aus.
Es gibt auf der einen Seite  Wasserdesinfektionstabletten, die du in deiner Dose drin hast.
Es gibt auch etwas anderes, Kaliumpermanganat, das schauen wir uns an.
Gut.
Zum Wasser desinfizieren genügt eine kleine
Messerspitze.
Jawohl, perfekt.
Klein genug?
In das Wasser geben, zumachen, schütteln, kurz warten und es ist vorbei.
Das nächste auf deiner Liste was du gerne haben würdest in der Natur?
Essen.
Gehen wir wieder zurück zum Feuer.
Zur Suppe fehlt uns noch irgendwie eine Einlage.
Oh Gott du hast gesammelt, alles klar.
Nur die besten Sachen.
Wir haben hier Brenneselblätter, gesammelt vom Breitwegerich und die Blätter vom Breitwegerich.
Dazu haben wir noch die Samen von den Brenneseln.
Man muss sich natürlich auskennen, das lernt man auch in der Ausbildung?
Ganz genau.
Einfach einen Schluck Wasser drauf jetzt?
Ja.
Gut, ich glaube jetzt ist es so weit oder?
Ja. Es ist soweit.
Gourmet Preise werden wir nicht kriegen dafür, aber zumindest sind wir jetzt satt.
Ok ich habe getrunken, habe gegessen, habe mich am Feuer aufgewärmt.
Jetzt bin ich müde.
Somit suchen wir uns einen Platz der schlecht einsichtig ist.
Da unten der Sägenwald bietet sich an, sehr dicht.
Ok.
Stopp, wenn wir direkt hingehen ziehen wir eine wunderbare Spur,
wo Spürhunde, etc. uns sofort finden würden.
Wir machen einen sogenannten Fishhook.
Einen Fischhaken?
Ja richtig, das hat diesen Sinn, wenn jetzt Hunde hinter uns her sind und wir im Versteck sind,
werden die Hunde genau uns hier nachgehen.
Ja.
Und vom Versteck aus werden wir die Hunde sehen.
Ihr habt es schon vorbereitet?
Richtig.
Ich habs von oben nicht gesehen.
Diese Unterkunft ist relativ schnell gebaut.
Es ist nichts anderes als ein Regenponcho.
Es riecht auch gut.
Du hast jetzt gelernt wie du eigentlich überlebst, Essen, Trinken, Unterkunft.
Kann sein, dass Feindkräfte im Raum sind.
Dazu musst du dich so gut wie es geht unsichtbar machen.
Ich habe hier etwas für dich.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ja.
Konzentriere dich auf die Nasenspitze, am Kinn ein bisschen, die Ohren sind auch vorstehend.
Moment meine Ohren sind überhaupt nicht vorstehend.
Um deinen Kopf zu tarnen.
So.
Zero One we are ready for pickup.
You can expect pickup in 1 minute.
Zero One copied, out.
Und liebe Grüße wollte ich noch sagen.
Alles Gute kommt von oben, in diesem Fall die Rettung.
Wie so eine Rettung aus der Luft aussieht,
das sehen wir uns jetzt gemeinsam an.